our girl stamp fair tax is fighting this
freaking weekend man you know she won
the first Adam weight MMA Grand Prix
girl she's fighting is on a nine fight
winning streak she's unbeaten in three
fights and one Championship I'm taking
stamp all freaking day she's so
entertaining and I get to see it
firsthand when I was in person and I
thought she was a big star like you know
kind of with the hard course here in
America dude when you see it in person
she's a superstar in Denver Colorado
over in Europe over in Asia she's just a
big star when she was walking out and
she does her dance she looks all cute
you're like you better get your mind
right girl and then she gets in there
and it's that's just her thing she's so
much fun to watch so damn entertaining
see her do her thing number one verse
number two is going down for the interim
Adam weight uh World title and MMA this
freaking weekend